there are a lot of amazing things about
how this story came together but to me
one of the most amazing things is that
this story was around the corner from
you and you didn't know about it can you
explain what I mean by that yes I've
lived in Kampala Uganda for 27 years
ever since I made Mississippi masala
there with themselv Washington 1989 as
when I went there and knowing the
paucity almost absence of films about
Africa or anything that resembled the
dignity on which around which I lived we
set up a film school called Maya about
12 years ago because if we don't tell
our own stories no one else will tell
them and the irony was surrounded by 12
years of these stories that the story of
Fiona moti she came to me from tender
niganda
fantastic Ugandan vice president of
Disney who came to my home in Kampala
and showed me this ESPN sports journal
article a little thing about how this
young girl you know who sold corn for a
living was now heading to Russia for the
chess Olympics and and literally 15
minutes from my home and I never knew
her and and then you know I immediately
was riveted because I'm always attracted
about people who are considered on the
margins of society and how they make
their work how they how they how they
find themselves and often through a
teacher through a family through a
mother through the whole prism that
makes her work and then this lovely
young lady at the far left where did you
find her and how long and far had you
been looking oh maybe now I must have
seen 700 young girls mostly in Uganda
and then also in Kenya and London but
and it was in January I had looked since
July and at the sixth month like in
January my close friend Dina Stafford
and my my son whom Medina calls her
girlfriend asked me about that one so
ron was her casting assistant she they
were taken to a young through a dance
company brother mark's dance company
called so solely a dance company in
shibuya which is the neighboring
community to cutaway and they've made a
little picture on the phone of medina
and rehearsal like in sweat and smiling
that
fantastic smile over there and I was
like first rolled my eyes like oh my god
another girl and then and I saw her it
was pretty arresting and but took about
three four weeks of very hard work on
the Medina's part to really get the role
you know because you have to know chess
you have to be taught by Robert and
Fiona you have to know how to think and
be comfortable you know thinking
on-screen and and also just
internalizing everything but you know
she is a real dancer an artist
discipline of an artist and that helped
so much because Medina has done
extraordinary work basically herself but
with all the training of being an artist
for so long she's been dancing since she
was four I'm gonna talk Alex a little
bit about music when you're thinking
about the role in which music and play
dramatically within a chess match what
were the conversations that you had with
Mira and how do you think music kind of
helped tell the story of what was maybe
a good move or a bad move
a gambit a stunt something like that and
how did you guys talk about music in
those scenes in particular well we did
didn't we drew up a chart with Barry of
some of the big games we actually had a
big chart on the wall so we could tell
where the bad news is where the good
news were where the tension was so that
the music without being too obvious can
lead the audience a little bit through
those games if you've never played a
game of chess before at least you know
what the stakes are you know what the
peaks and troughs are we were shooting
designed games actual games that Fiona
had real game moves that she had made
and was famous for so in total the
notation yeah without Col she have the
cold designed game that Robert Bettany
taught everyone but I knew I was filming
that but I knew I was not going to show
all of that so we knew in advance which
moments were to be heightened and it was
actually a very careful thing with the
choreography it is really I want to ask
David and the PETA about the what I'll
call the curtain call it's a beautiful
scene at the end of the film where you
come out with the people that you play
Tim Carruthers has written a beautiful
book about this story but there's
probably something that transcends the
book about what you can learn
about the character you're playing when
the person is there with you David I'll
start with you about your conversations
with Robert and what it was about him
that you saw in him personally that
maybe wasn't captured in the book that
you wanted to bring to the screen well
in in meeting Robert and in watching
actually mirrors I think it's about
12-minute kind of documentary that she
had sent me a folk a spoon and a night
which is a beautiful documentary that
really captures the person of Robert and
then talking to him on the phone and
then meeting him in person to be
perfectly honest I had very real
trepidation about playing him because he
is a saint
I mean it's a and that typically
speaking is not the most interesting
thing to play on film you want someone
who has some edge to them who you know
who is human Robert and and mischievous
see oh yeah oh no and then I and then
with time with time he's he's not that
saintly but but no but that was the
thing that was initially intimidating
and you know also yes that the book
captures that but the thing that the
book doesn't capture as much and what I
got from being around him is just how
truthful the level of selflessness that
Robert has is you know the cost to
himself his wife was pregnant while we
were shooting this film they haven't had
an another child already they live in a
relatively small place and they had
another six kids living with them at the
time who just needed a place to say so
they have to stay so you know that
that's just the way it is and I just
thought that is so beautiful and when
you talk to Robert himself you know he
was orphaned at a at a young age went
through very real difficulty and I asked
him what is it that drives you what is
it that motivates you to do what you do
and he said to give them what I didn't
have
and then also that if just one of them
has and I'll never forget this you
saying this to me I remember it being
over lunch Robert if just one of them
has a greater self-esteem because of
something I've said to them didn't about
chess something I've said to them that's
the reward for me not easy to play
so-so you know but that that was the
thing about being around him and and you
know leaving this film leaving being
around him really in a very true sense
made me want to go into my life being a
better person
Robert is clapping there
lupita can I ask you about Harriet and
about the conversations that you had
with her I met Harriet about three weeks
before we started filming Robert took me
to meet her she doesn't speak English so
he was my interpreter and I sat with her
and what I found in her presence was
this she has she's so grounded and she
has a very mysterious kind of enigmatic
quality to her she's also very guarded
but very warm as well and I asked her a
lot about her youth and she came for a
very unstable background she was tossed
around from mother to father to
grandmother aunt she told me a story of
having to walk two days to find her
mother because she'd broken a door and
she was afraid of the consequences with
her stepmother and so when it came to
her children she too wanted to provide
them with something she didn't have
which was stability and togetherness you
know so she strove to keep them together
and that's something that really
resonated with me and I wanted to honor
that quality in her she was also very
practical I asked her why she first let
Fiona go to Robert and she said it was
because he could provide her with a cup
of porridge when I couldn't and Robert
himself admitted to me in her presence
how long it took for her to finally
trust him with her daughter and so that
she was just fear
mostly fiercely fiercely protective of
her children and that's something that I
deeply admired Medina did you have the
same chance to spend time with Fiona as
you're making the movie and what did you
guys talk about
um when I met Fiona my first time to
meet to meet Fiona it wasn't said she
was in school but one day she came to
set I mean she came we met and when we
met I never had any problem with her she
she just asked me how do you feel at all
I told her I feel very fine
because what I'm doing is from my head
and what I'm doing is like my story so
I'm doing the same thing I'm supposed to
do and when we met she just smiled to me
and I did the same thing to her yeah in
terms of what you want this movie to
look like and the way in which you want
to depict these neighborhoods poverty
the people who live in them what were
the important things that you kept
repeating that you kept talking about
your department heads about what you
wanted this movie to be and I guess at
the same time what you didn't want it to
be well this is a movie really that is
made from the inside as I said I have
lived I live in these places and I have
longed to make visual illusions to the
both the vibrancy that color of the
earth the greenness of the Equator runs
through my garden I mean the line of the
Equator so everything is incredibly
fertile you know in Uganda it's
remarkable that's why there's not the
poverty is not about begging bowls
because people have a tree in the ground
and they get avocados from it even where
the family lived in tabbouleh in the
film in katway there is an avocado tree
you know so it's an unusual place where
there is a lot of struggle but the
despair is mitigated you know and I
wanted so much to tell that both the
colors but also the sassiness and the
smartness of style to be smart is
a lot in Uganda you have to be whatever
if you have half an inch of water in a
basin you will still wash your hair and
look very elegant for the end of it you
know that's the spirit of the people I
live with so I really wanted to capture
that in the style and in the look and in
the color and in the flamboyance even of
it because it is also this for instance
they used clothes capital of the world
Uganda and everyone wear Harriet goes to
sell her dresses the market or we know
and everyone dresses from a we know even
middle class upper middle class people
and you my fish seller the other day had
a Pucci original Pucci dress on with a
Katanga wrap around her that's just the
style it is and I looked at her brand
and I said oh my god what you wearing I
mean that's that's what they are the
stories there but so you know it was
great to work with Shan Bobbitt who is a
real a child of Africa he's made several
films there he knows it also from within
and with miles Goodall another
cinematographer the second
cinematographer and that combination was
beautiful for this film an observational
feeling and then an immersive feeling of
two kinds of cameras but Stephanie
Carroll the production designer has done
many of my films from monsoon wedding to
Kama Sutra to many films and she just
her eye is impeccable so even though the
places are real the locations are also
real I put harriet in gaba that's my
local film fishing village where she
sells because the lake victoria is there
and you can't make a film or a story
about Kampala without the Lake Victoria
which is as big as the ocean and in the
center of the city so I chose the
locations were more than anything the
design but Stephanie's I enhanced always
the design I want to thank you guys for
showing up and I'm gonna thank you guys
for making this amazing movie